[Música]
la presidenta de Perú Dina boluarte
volvió a pedir perdón por las alrededor
de 60 vidas perdidas en medio de las
protestas y enfrentamientos que golpean
el país y llamó una vez más al diálogo y
a convocar una tregua nacional la
mandataria dijo que la violencia que se
vive es responsabilidad de radicales el
martes se registraron nuevos choques
entre manifestantes y las autoridades en
Lima la capital
con una declaración de 111 puntos
finalizó en Buenos Aires la séptima
cumbre de la celac una cita que dejó en
evidencia el acuerdo de la región para
proteger las democracias al tiempo que
mostró divisiones en temas como la
propuesta de moneda común ampliamos
desde la capital Argentina
América Latina tendrá presencia en los
Oscar 2023 la cinta Argentina 1985 fue
nominada a mejor película internacional
el filme retrata la lucha de la justicia
civil para conseguir la condena de las
juntas militares que gobernaron ese país
durante la última dictadura en France 24
dialogamos con Alejandra freshner actriz
argentina y una de las protagonistas
[Música]
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos damos inicio en
Perú donde la presidenta Dina boluarte
pidió una tregua nacional para el
diálogo en medio de un estallido social
que deja alrededor de 60 muertos la
mandataria reiteró su apoyo a las
fuerzas del orden acusadas de reprimir
violentamente a los manifestantes y
cargó contra la llamada agenda política
de las protestas criminalizando a los
organizadores justamente el martes Se
volvieron a presentar choques entre los
ciudadanos y las autoridades en Lima en
el sexto día consecutivo de
movilizaciones en la capital peruana
Marina sardinho tiene los detalles
disculpas el respaldo a las fuerzas del
orden y su negativa renunciar son 50
personas que han fallecido en mitad de
estos actos de protesta y de violencia
y me duele cuando se van a cumplir seis
semanas de protestas antigubernamentales
en Perú la presidenta Dina boluarte hizo
un llamado a una tregua nacional para
restablecer el diálogo con los miles de
manifestantes pero atribuyó al caos y la
violencia de las últimas semanas a
grupos radicales reiterando su apoyo a
las actuaciones policiales durante las
protestas Pese a que organismos
humanitarios y manifestantes denuncian
una brutal represión eso es una acción
violento generado por un grupo
de personas
radicales que tienen como agenda agenda
política y económica Este martes los
manifestantes volvieron a salir
pacíficamente a las calles para exigir
entre otros pedidos la renuncia de
boluarte a quien acusan de estar detrás
de las más de 60 muertes durante el
estallido estábamos viniendo por toda
esta Avenida de manera pacífica y de
repente esta policía mira todo diseñada
todo organizada para poder bloquearnos
creen que somos bandas asesinos
terroristas No señores aquí nosotros
marchamos de manera pacífica por el
momento boluarte apuntó que no dejará el
cargo hasta que no se celebre en
elecciones y pese a su llamado a una
tregua los organizadores de las marchas
reclaman su renuncia como condición para
las mesas de diálogo
donde no hay democracia no hay paz Ellos
dicen diálogo pero diálogo para qué Para
el agua para el desagüe para carreteras
no el pueblo existe acá una salida
política y la salida política Es que la
señora
el miércoles la mandataria tendrá una
reunión con la comisión permanente de la
oea señalando que contará la verdad
terminó la séptima cumbre de la
comunidad de Estados latinoamericanos y
caribeños celac que tuvo lugar en Buenos
Aires Argentina el encuentro destacó el
llamado multilateralismo solidario en la
declaración de Buenos Aires con la que
se cerró la cita el documento tiene 100
puntos de consenso y once declaraciones
especiales con ella según palabras del
canciller argentino Santiago fafero se
podrá vencer la cultura del odio y
defender la democracia la recuperación
económica y el desarrollo previamente
natalio cosoil corresponsal en Buenos
Aires nos amplió detalles del documento
terminó esta cumbre de la celaque en
Buenos Aires con el traspaso de la
presidencia pro tempore de Argentina a
San Vicente y Las Granadinas una de las
naciones más pequeñas de la región que
se encuentra en el Caribe los 33
representantes de los estados que
participaron en este encuentro y que
forman parte de la celac llegaron a un
consenso que se tradujo en una
declaración de Buenos Aires con 111
puntos en los que se insiste mucho en la
integración regional en el pedido de
financiamiento internacional
también se habló de la exigencia de que
se levante el bloqueo contra Cuba
también del respaldo a las negociaciones
entre el gobierno y la oposición en
Venezuela se defendió las instituciones
democráticas pero también la no
intervención en los asuntos de los
estados nacionales y a lo largo de la
Cumbre hubo bastante apoyo respaldo y
celebración por el ingreso de Brasil a
este foro
en el estado estadounidense de
California se llevó a cabo una vigilia
por las víctimas de los tiroteos del
sábado y el lunes en total 18 personas
perdieron la vida en los hechos con
velas y ofrendas florales los ciudadanos
se reunieron en Monterrey Park para
pedir justicia y un mayor control de las
armas de fuego justamente Este martes el
presidente Joe biden volvió a solicitar
que se prohíba en las armas de asalto
pues el lunes hubo otro tiroteo de nayo
o en el que dos estudiantes murieron y
en la madrugada del martes tres personas
perdieron la vida en una balacera en el
estado de Washington estas fueron las
palabras del mandatario
Así que la conclusión aquí es que
tenemos mucho de qué hablar ayer mi
amiga Diana Einstein re introdujo su
prohibición de armas de asalto en el
senado les pido a todos que envíen eso a
mi escritorio lo más rápido que puedan
la enviado especial de Naciones Unidas
para Haití declaró ante el Consejo de
Seguridad que la violencia relacionada
con las bandas criminales alcanzó
niveles no vistos en décadas de acuerdo
con el reporte solo en 2022 hubo 1.359
secuestros un delito que al igual que
los asesinatos lleva cuatro años en
aumento alcanzando los 2.183 el año
pasado el organismo internacional
reiteró su llamado para que sea enviada
al país caribeño una fuerza
internacional que sirva para garantizar
seguridad y de tranquilidad para retomar
el rumbo político social y económico
en Guatemala las autoridades de
migración anunciaron que los ciudadanos
dominicanos tendrán que obtener visa
para ingresar al país esto argumentando
que en 2022 se evidenció Un aumento de
personas provenientes de República
Dominicana que transitan irregularmente
con el fin de llegar a Estados Unidos el
año pasado Guatemala negó el ingreso de
casi 1400 dominicanos mientras que en
2021 la cifra fue de sólo 474
América Latina estará presente en la
entrega de los premios Oscar 2023 la
película argentina 1985 resultó nominada
en la categoría a mejor película
internacional la industria
cinematográfica Argentina llega a los
premios Oscar nuevamente lo hace con una
cinta de Santiago mitre que retrata la
lucha del fiscal Julio César trasera
para conseguir la condena de las juntas
militares que gobernaron el país
suramericano durante su última dictadura
militar en el programa la entrevista de
France 24 dialogamos con Alejandra
freshner actriz argentina y una de las
protagonistas que nos contó como Recibió
la nominación
son muchas emociones esta película nos
nos viene dando muchas emociones desde
su estreno en el festival de Venecia que
se veía al público por primera vez Yo
tuve la fortuna de estar en ese lugar y
lo que vivimos esa noche fue algo
inolvidable Porque además vimos por
primera vez la película con público
Entonces ahora Bueno uno ya sabe que la
gente le encanta lo que la película es
sucede lo que sucede pero esa primera
vez fue como muy alucinante y todo el
recorrido de la película internacional
fue muy alucinante muy loco a veces
pensar que un hecho de si bien es una
ficción pero es sobre nuestra historia
sobre un momento muy importante de
nuestra historia
no te imaginas que en otros lugares
pueda tener ese esa resonancia creo que
la película
La tiene muy fuerte primero porque
dialoga muy fuerte con el presente un
mundo violento digo que rompe pactos
democráticos que quiere golpes de estado
o discursos de odio y hoy la película
nos viene como a recordar no a muchas
cosas a poner en valor muchísimas
cuestiones segundo que las personas
jóvenes las propias de nuestro país las
chicas nos pidan los pibes de quince
años le pregunten a sus padres y vos qué
dónde estabas en el cuando fueron los
coches a las juntas tenías diez años
sabías lo que estaba pasando esa
conversación que se dio en Argentina no
solo a nivel internacional sino dentro
de nuestro propio país la película fue
un acontecimiento social y eso es es
mucho más de lo que una película puede
aspirar fin del informativo volvemos en
breve
[Música]